le convoi est enfin arrivé cela aura
pris deux jours pour parcourir 250 km
les évacués sont épuisés mais sain et
sauf après une vérification d'identité
ils recevront l'aide dont ils ont besoin
dans ce centre d'accueil
certains acceptent de raconter un peu de
ce qu'ils ont vécu vos va lui a juste 14
ans
mais on est resté deux mois sans jamais
voir le soleil dit il on n'a pas bougé
de l'abri souterrain il ajoute qu'il ne
mangeait que du gruau et des plantes
qu'ils pouvaient trouver au pire c'était
les bombardements qui était incessant
votre cagnotte
vers la fin dit tatiana et larguer des
bombes à sous munitions avec des
parachutes elle explosait au bout de 30
secondes en libérant beaucoup d'éclat
pour faire plus de victimes
tous resteront marqués par ces jours
passés entre la vie et la mort sans eau
sans électricité sans chauffage
seulement une centaine d'entre eux ont
pu s'extraire cette fois de l'immense
complexe beaucoup d'autres on ignore
combien sont encore terrés dans les
dédales souterrains
peut-être parce qu'ils ont ils avaient
trop peur mais je pense enfin j'espère
que le fait que nous avons arriver tous
les gens sont arrivés ici
sain et sauf aux apories j'ai
sans
aucun problème donc peut-être ça va
donner le courage aux autres de sortie
cloud ou d'y placer je vous en supplie
implore cette femme il ya encore
quarante deux personnes qui étaient avec
nous dans l'abri il ya des jeunes de 15
16 17 ans il faut les sortir de là parce
que les bombardements continus et en
plus des civils il ya tous les
militaires qui continuent de se battre
le père de vos vins est encore là bas
ce que le show je veux lui dire qu'on
est sauvé dit-il j'espère qu'il sera
prudent
en attendant les rescapés peuvent manger
un peu reprendre leur souffle les
enfants reçoivent quelques jouets et
retrouvent leur sourire
les nains et sa fille sont
reconnaissantes d'avoir enfin pu quitter
mario paul de chez elles elles ont été
témoins de toute la destruction des
obstacles
en cause de notre balcon on a vu ce qui
s'est passé il ne reste plus rien tout
est réduit en cendres et elles repartent
avec tout ce qu'elle possède maintenant
quelques sacs mais au moins elles sont
ensemble est encore en vie céline
galipeau radio canada zappos ridja